celery juice why hey everyone i'm abby
sharp
welcome to abby's kitchen
today's video is sponsored by
squarespace and we will be reviewing
lifestyle darling gen m but first
let's talk about my sponsor squarespace
so i remember when i started
abby's kitchen getting the whole website
going
seemed like the biggest hurdle and i
hear that same thing from
a lot of new hopeful bloggers that i
coach
who maybe are just less tech savvy or
just rightfully feel overwhelmed with
all of the options and choices
but squarespace really does take the
guesswork out of building
a website blog or online store they have
so
many amazing features for e-commerce
setting up members only areas accessing
analytics
and integrating social media i have been
so impressed
by how easy and simple they pull
together all of the hard parts of
getting a business or passion project
off the ground
so that way you can focus on what you do
best so if you're interested in getting
started you can check out
squarespace.com
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch go to squarespace.com
slash abbey sharp to save 10 off of your
first purchase of a website or domain
and before we hop into this
check out my disclaimer on screen or in
the description along with a trigger
warning
for those with disordered eating
histories you can definitely feel free
to skip this video if
what i eat in a daily content is not
supportive to you and your journey
all right folks so jen is a korean
american fashion and beauty vlogger who
started her youtube
clothes encounters very cute over about
a decade ago
and now has amassed millions of fans and
followers
and since i started watching her thanks
to all your suggestions
i 100 understand the appeal
also a side note this is the most recent
what i eat in a week at the time i'm
filming this and i know i'm
filming this ahead of time so please do
not crucify me if
it's not her most recent one let's take
a look
gotta start the video off with a little
celery juice b-roll
classic lifestyle influencer trope now
normally i would rant for like 20
minutes about this
but i think i've discussed celery juice
enough on this channel
bottom line it's just expensive water
with a little bit of nutrition in it and
some flavor
and color if you love said flavor and
color
and nutrition amazing drink that
up but there's no magical health
benefits to celery juice
above just drinking regular water and
eating celery
thankfully i've watched a lot of jen's
content but of course not
everything so feel free to correct me
here and unlike a lot of celery juice
peddlers
i don't ever hear jen plug the like
virtues of
medical medium or wax poetic about how
celery juice cures cancer and reduces
bloating
or is involved in some other [ __ ] in
fact she doesn't really say anything at
all about it so
my guess is that she just likes the
flavor or finds it refreshing
or thinks it's like an easy way to
hydrate which of course
it is not my style but i'm not gonna
yuck someone's young so if she loves it
i love it now after the juice which she
seems to have a few times this week we
get into jen's
actual breakfast now what i love here is
that jen isn't afraid to switch things
up
and that is always great since i always
say that the healthiest diet is a varied
diet
so we see avocado toast with the perfect
poached egg
yogurt parfaits with granola and fruit a
fruit smoothie bowl
topped with granola a protein smoothie
with fruit spinach and protein powder
and my favorite breakfast of the week a
nutrient
dense overnight oats let's take a look
i absolutely love this is a
delicious looking and perfectly balanced
make-ahead breakfast
love it we have fiber-rich carbs from
the oats and fruit
plus some healthy fats and protein in
the nuts and seeds
but what i really love about this meal
is how jen talks about the oats she
doesn't go on about how they're clean or
healthy or how low sugar they are
she straight up just starts to
romanticize their texture
and just talks about how much she likes
them and that my friends
is how you make naturally nourishing
food
super exciting that's what makes you
want to choose more nutrient dense meals
every single day and we see this
attitude when she dives into
a lot of her meals so for example one
day she has just
straight up oranges and watermelon for
breakfast describing it as the perfect
combination because
watermelon is like sweet with a good
structure
while orange is tangy and juicy and soft
obviously this for example is not the
most balanced substantial breakfast
as it is lacking a source of protein and
fat
but judging by all of her other choices
that week
she clearly knows how to assemble a
really balanced breakfast bowl
so this may have just been a morning
that she was not very hungry
and when you're listening to your body
like that that's to be expected
we're not all like robots
serp robot
with perfectly calibrated calorie
counters
our metabolism appetite and cravings are
expected to vary
from day to day or within the day so
that makes total sense to me but let's
take a look at lunch
now like breakfast jen's lunch is
always exciting and new so sometimes
it's leftover curry or fried rice from
the dinner before
other times she's able to whip something
up really quick using a few grocery
store staples
like baked salad so one day she has
these halloumi lettuce wraps which
sidenote totally makes me yearn for the
salty squeak of a good
slice of halloumi love it other days
it's like garlic pan fried chicken on
salad with avocado and sesame dressing
another is a spinach wrap stuffed with
veggie nuggets and vegan cream cheese
and another day is baked salad with
leftover veggie wellington
roasted potato and gravy oh my gosh
that looks unreal i would say that if we
are trying to
really optimize each meal for satiety
sometimes her lunches
can be a little bit lower carb so for
example
in the case of the chicken salad she
could throw in some cooked rice
or serve it with pita or bread but of
course
in real life in the context of her
higher carb snacks and breakfast
everything typically evens out now even
though
the entire video gave me mad food envy
i would say that my favorite lunch of
her week
was her korean party noodles
friends let's take a look and get
inspired
[Music]
how awesome does that look
so we've got some protein and fat from
the shredded cooked eggs
carbs from the noodles and lots of
stir-fried veggies
so kelp aka seaweed is also a really
great source of vitamin k
folate and magnesium plus a variety of
carotenoid and flavonoid antioxidants
so it's also a really great nutrient
dense way to add a ton of nutrition
and flavor to a simple soup broth i also
want to mention how jen makes food
choices
based less on external factors like a
nutrition panel
or the latest diet trend and instead
focuses on how food makes her feel
physically and emotionally let's take a
look for my lunch i have my leftover
fried rice this is the last of it and
just to make it a little bit more
substantial i
steamed three dumplings and
i have the purdue salsa on the side
you know it's just so good with the
freaking dumplings man and last time i
actually didn't get any heartburn so
okay so from watching some of jen's
content
i have learned that she like 15 to 30
percent of adults
gets pretty bad heartburn so she loves
this super
spicy sauce and i also love super spicy
sauces
but she knows the sunlight too much heat
can exacerbate her symptoms
so based on some experimentation however
she's been able to determine
that if she's careful with her portion
sizes of the spicy sauce
she can keep that burn sensation at bay
this is what intuitive eating is all
about
it's not about denying yourself a food
that you love outright
but about collecting data over time on
how
food makes you feel and then making an
educated choice
on what you're going to do with that
knowledge sometimes eating a food that
you really
love is maybe worth the uncomfortable
consequence
and other times maybe it's not that is
just for you to decide and it's a
totally personal thing but let's switch
gears and talk about jen's dinner
i love jen's dinners because they often
bring in some of her korean roots
which honestly is so inspiring for me to
see from chicken and brown rice lettuce
wraps with kimchi
and veggies to salad with veggie
dumplings avocado and chicken
to fries curry and a dumpling
soup all of her meals feel generally
well balanced
and in totally normal portions for a
young girl like jen
now let's take a look at these amazing
looking chicken
lettuce wraps
[Music]
oh my goodness i am a very happy girl
oh my god i'm so excited to eat this
i've been craving this for a couple of
days
so i'm gonna first get my sesame leaf i
put a little samjhang on it
[Music]
honestly tell me this isn't the most
satisfying and inspiring
what i eat in the day you have ever seen
watching
her eat with so much unapologetic
enthusiasm
actually reminds me of one of my
favorite movie food scenes of all time
the make-believe food scene from robin
williams
hook
everybody say grace bless this old
[Applause]
doesn't that just bring you back to
simpler times when eating wasn't so
damn complicated by die culture and
rules
ugh good times anyways speaking of
diet culture jen also doesn't seem to
have
too many qualms or concerns about
indulging in an amazing looking pizza
dinner
on a random monday night let's watch
we just ordered from one of our favorite
pizza spots called
wood we've got a margherita pizza a four
cheese truffle pizza
a chopped salad healthy and then i got
these
uh balls i kind of want to try these
balls first is it like
uh cheese and potato or something i'm
not sure actually
that girl just face planted straight
into that cheesy deep-fried eranchini
without any qualifiers
or justification of her choice as being
like a cheat meal
or some kind of splurge or indulgence
this
is the kind of what i eat in a day
i want to watch now if we're looking at
these meals
at a macro level there's lots to love
about jen's meals as well
so we typically have some kind of
protein like chicken
or tofu fat in the avocado or cooking
oil
carbs like dumplings potatoes or rice
and lots of veggies like eggplant corn
broccoli and carrots
she even gets a little salad to balance
out her pizza dinner
and i mean i usually don't even do that
so yeah
nothing i'm seeing here reads as diet
food
and it appears that she actually loves
all of the food that she eats
finally let's round this out talking
briefly about her snacks and desserts
which are generally
fruit like watermelon or orange or on
one occasion
a delicious looking matcha scone with
butter
that i feel like i need in my life all
good options if you just need like a
little something to carry you between
meals
but of course if we wanted to bump up
the satiety factor
we could bring in the principles of my
hunger crushing combination
so maybe pairing that fruit with a
little nuts
or cheese or yogurt and the scone could
be with some
cashew breader as a spread and on that
note let's talk about the stats here and
again trigger warning
you can skip to the time stamp on the
screen if you want to avoid hearing any
numbers
in this section but according to some
very crude estimations
jen is consuming on average somewhere
around 1600 to 1700 calories
with a totally normal balanced
macronutrient split of about 50
of her calories coming from carbs 30
from fat
and 20 from protein she's getting lots
of fiber and antioxidants
thanks to all of that colorful produce
in her diet so
the only thing that i see as potentially
lacking most days
are iron calcium and vitamin d
which are very common nutrients of
concern for young women
now let's talk about what i like here
and friends
i gotta say abby likey like
i am low-key kind of obsessed with this
girl now
just saying but first of all i love how
varied jen's meals are across this week
i think this is the first
what i eat in a week that i've watched
that doesn't feature
literally the same breakfast garnished
slightly differently every single day
and there's nothing wrong with having a
solid breakfast routine
so no judgment here let's be real most
of us don't have the mental energy to
think up
new innovative recipes in the early
morning before we've even had our coffee
but somehow jen makes this whole thing
look super doable her recipes feel
pretty accessible inexpensive easy and
fast
and when she does cook a big batch of
something she knows that she can just
throw it into rotation as leftovers the
next day i also appreciate that the
ingredients she focuses on
are generally budget friendly and easy
to find so
lots of noodles veggies oats frozen
dumplings
tofu and fruit all good things now let's
consider some
gentle nutrition tips for jen based on
this week
honestly i think that jen is doing an
amazing job balancing a desire for
nutrition
and a drive for pleasure it doesn't seem
like she's ever overthinking her food
choices
she just listens to what her body tells
her feels good
and what doesn't and lets that guide her
choices
so for example the girl loves her spicy
hot sauce you can just
tell that it brings her joy but she
knows that spicy food
sets off her heartburn so she carefully
tests the waters at
different amounts and with different
foods to see how much
you can tolerate this is what intuitive
eating and gentle nutrition is about
it's about collecting individual data on
how
food makes you feel not following an
arbitrary set of hard and fast universal
rules
but just going off of her nutrient
analysis i would say that she could
probably
bump up the iron in her diet by maybe
throwing in some more dark leafy greens
into her soups or stir fries
adding some extra legumes like lentils
or chickpeas to stir fries and curries
topping her breakfast bowls off with
maybe some pumpkin seeds
and swapping quinoa for rice some days
of the week
she could also easily boost the calcium
in her diet by choosing tofu that's made
with
calcium phosphate and also by adding in
like a handful of frozen edamame to some
of her salads or soups
and if she loves her hot sauce and wants
to try some other ways to enjoy the heat
without the discomfort of her heartburn
here are a few
little tips number one you can serve
that spicy sauce
with a smaller meal so this might mean
splitting a dinner or lunch into two
smaller
mini meals or having it as like a
smaller meal
but then bulking up her fruit snack with
a source of fat and protein
two she could try having any spicy meals
earlier on in the day so that she isn't
laying down right afterwards which
again can make heartburn worse three if
she does have a spicy meal at dinner
she could plan to go for a little walk
afterwards to get things moving before
she lays down to go to sleep
and four pick your heartburn battles if
you want to add a lot of heat to your
dinner
maybe go easy on other heartburn
triggering ingredients like alcohol
citrus chocolate tomatoes higher fat
foods and
carbonated drinks at the same meal or
day i want to now finish off talking
briefly about jen's relationship with
her body
and food now reminder that what i see
here on the channel tells me very little
about
someone's true relationship with food
but i'm basing this off of the videos
that i watched
first of all can i just say that i am an
official
jen subby it is so refreshing to watch a
youtuber go through their day
and not have to go off on how one food
cures brain fog
and the other one banishes bloat the
commentary around
jen's meals are solely based in
excitement
and joy not wellness rhetoric and
pseudoscience
so for example there's this video where
she's making a
strawberry sando and it legit puts me
in a good mood for the rest of the day
i'm gonna let you guys watch it in case
you too would like to have a good day oh
my god
wow oh my god it's so beautiful
oh my god this brings me so much joy i
can't believe i did this
it's show time see doesn't that just
like
lift your spirits this to me does more
for my
serotonin levels than like a snuggly
puppy dog
screensaver happy people making happy
food
and being happy eating it we need more
happy morally neutral food content on
youtube
love it and then there was this video
where her and her partner ben did like a
fry off competition
which again youtube gold i think it's
clear who won
it's not about the cover of the book
it's what's inside the book you made a
fry tower
but generally speaking i love that jen
talks about
food as helping you feel good and well
nourished
not light or flat and in all the videos
i watched i only think i heard her say
the word
clean once and she was kind of using it
as a synonym for healthy eating which
again i don't love i don't love the word
but i would say it's pretty encouraging
since you could probably get blackout
drunk in the first five minutes of
most of the videos that i review here if
you were to make a drinking game
out of youtubers use of the word clean
but hopefully if we can all just band
together
we can eliminate that word from our
wellness
lexicon and use it only to describe you
know washing our hands
so jen if you're watching gather the
troops
and let's make this happen now i also
want to acknowledge that this
attitude wasn't always necessarily easy
for jen in her december video on body
image
she talks about the progress that she's
made in her own relationship with her
body
let's take a quick look historically in
the past
every time i would go on any type of
trip i would come home
like feeling fat it's because when i'm
on
like these trips i am eating i'm
indulging i'm drinking i'm doing
everything
and then after i would have this wave of
guilt like oh my gosh i can't believe
you had brownies
every single night i would just kind of
psychologically punish myself
it's like the first time i have been
showing my body
some compassion like a body is meant to
expand contract it's gonna droop when
we're gonna get older
it's just a part of life except my body
as it is
because if i'm not going to accept my
body the way it is now
if i lose 10 pounds i'm still gonna find
something to that i want to change about
it so jen talks about how
like so many of us we get out of the
holiday season having consumed
a lot of rich food and booze and as a
result
we end up feeling guilty and fat but jen
says that this time
she hasn't been body checking or
criticizing her body so
i love that she's showing her body some
compassion and learning to
embrace where she's at today because i
absolutely agree
you know most of the time reaching for
one aesthetic goal
just leads to a fixation on something
else so i'm really loving the shift in
mentality towards a goal of
self-acceptance
and self-love rather than a physical
desire to
lose 10 pounds and according to jen
journaling really helped her to reach
those goals and to trust her body so
i know a lot of you guys asked me how to
respect your body
even if maybe you don't like the way
that it looks and i've got a whole video
on this that i'm going to link below
but i also think that trying to do some
more introspective
activities like journaling can
definitely help and on that note folks
that is
all that i have for you guys today thank
you again to squarespace for sponsoring
this video
if you liked it be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below on
who you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye